thing that people may not understand
about drinking is that people all
understand it affects your memory right
the effect of the memory also affects
your ability to learn and feel pain and
damage emotionally that you've caused so
you don't connect this horrible feeling
in your body with your own actions I
started drinking to blackout at 14. so
here I am suddenly I'm 36 with the
emotional ability of a 14 year old
trying to get through life and I had to
learn all that I know I get
probably get it wrong more than I'd like
but I'm not here to pretend that life's
amazing and Rosy it's not it's
hard but it's also it's worth it it's
worth trying because who I get to be
because of the trying is worth it